bom dia meu nome é tácito cury
eu sou um sobrevivente eu sobrevivi um
dos piores atentados nossa história
catástrofe 23 60 em 2004 eu sobrevivo
tsunami
em 2008 eu sobrevivi uma das piores
crises financeiras que abalaram todos os
mercados e desde os 17 anos eu venho
sobrevivendo longe de casa de um lugar
chamado meu espaço meu lar e hoje eu
trago para vocês cinco lições para
compartilhar com vocês sim condições que
me ajudaram a sobreviver neste mundo aí
afora
para que vocês possam se você precisar o
dia aplicar na sua vida
bom desde a minha infância eu fui muito
motivado pela minha mãe
a estudar ela conseguiu mudar a minha
vida fazer com que a escola não fosse um
cara chato que realmente fosse um lugar
de recreação a 8 ela me colocava em tudo
quanto era curso tudo quanto era há
oficinas
eu fazia tudo desde cursos de teatro
música folclore dança só os cursos de
datilografia fiz uns três cursos de
datilografia naquela época a sd fg
porque eu não consegui a nota boa
eu sempre estava estudando e ocupando
todo o tempo todo o tempo
então foi aí já desde criança da minha
infância que eu aprendi a aprender ea
desenvolver a minha primeira lição é o
primeiro conceito eo primeiro conceito
foi a minha primeira lição é não
acredite na inércia sempre esteja em
movimento porque você tem que se mover
você tem que sempre está fazendo alguma
coisa estou sempre ligado no 220 nunca
paro nem aqui no palco um conselho para
então se estou conectado e essa lição
fez mais sentido pra mim quando tive a
primeira oportunidade meu primeiro
trabalho
eu fui trabalhar numa loja e às vezes
quando se trabalha numa loja com
vendedor geralmente você fica com os
braços cruzados esperando que o cliente
entre dependendo do movimento da loja
fiz o contrário eu fiz uma sinergia de
dentro pra fora eu comecei bagunçava
arrumado desorganizar organizado
começava
o braço roupas e andar de um lado para o
outro para que as pessoas lá fora vi que
estava acontecendo algum movimento
alguma promoção entrar se comprasse
alguma coisa eu ficava criando um
movimento essa era era sempre a minha
idéia e aí
dada a a mesma coisa já está dormindo a
gente tá dormindo a região está se
mexendo de um lado para o outro a gente
está com a inquietude ea gente tá
naquela zona de desconforto e os 17 anos
já me encontrava nessa zona de
desconforto
ai dado domingo porque domingo já em dia
a dia da gente como macarrão pelo menos
eu comer macarrão e assistiu silvio
santos eo santos vinha com aquela que
aquela martelando na cabeça da gente se
um dia vocês forem para nova york
não esqueça de visitar a famosa aberta
brasil boutique
não sei se você se lembra e aí eu falei
eu já sei para onde eu vou eu vou pra
nova york é pra lá que eu vou
eu acabei indo para nova york mas aí eu
me planejei muda organizei minha vida
inteira por causa daquele comercial eu
ouvia que é pra lá que eu ia e aí vem a
minha primeira dica pra vocês como vocês
tiveram um objetivo muito grande muito
complexo que mudar de país algo muito
difícil você tem que ter metas claras
definidas sustentável estrutura e bem
parruda muita gente fala olha taxa ficou
em 122 países é o meu sonho viajar para
fora que mais sabe aí eu falo que bom
que você quer fazer lá fora vai falar eu
quero dar uma qualidade de vida melhor
para minha família e para mim e falou
olha isso aí você tem que dar uma
qualidade de vida melhor para sua
família onde quer que você esteja aqui
na china na coréia você tem que ir pra
lá com metas bem definidas e os 17 anos
já sabe o que eu queria fui pra lá com
três metas bem claras e definidas
eu fui lá perdido eu fui lá porque
queria mamar um carro de uma marca bem
específica eu queria estudar teatro na
escola já decidido eu queria aprender
inglês mas eu não queria aprender inglês
pra falar inglês e quer aprender inglês
para lecionar para dar aula de inglês
então colocava esses objetivos impressos
atrás da minha porte todo dia quando
levantava ouvir seus objetivos para me
dar ânimo porque às vezes é claro que
não é tão fácil assim
fui para os estados unidos e aí eu
comecei a desenvolver aprendi o idioma e
conforme você vai aprendendo e é o que
eu falo pra vocês
ah eu consegui avançar evoluir na minha
vida profissional porque eu comecei a
dominar as regras do jogo que vem a
minha segunda lição
no meu caso a regra do jogo o jogo era
aprender inglês era meu cartão de visita
eu precisava falar bem eu precisava
dominar
então conforme o qual eu comecei a
dominar conforme comecei a aprender
inglês
eu comecei tempo ter mais oportunidades
e aí eu comecei trabalhando é eu saí do
serviço braçal e comecei a trabalhar
numa primeira escola
aí comecei a trabalhar na primeira
escola comecei como recepcionista e
terminei como diretor de marketing em
uma startup a gente faz de tudo e aí
como eu sabia dar aulas de inglês porque
eu tinha aprendido inglês mas é preciso
um tempo eu acabei também dando aulas de
inglês dando aula de inglês para todo
mundo gente de todas as nacionalidades e
raças e de certos e essa unidade essa
escola tinha dois locais mantendo do
world trade center e uma em outra
unidade e um dado dia estava indo
trabalhar e aí só que esse dinheiro dia
11 de setembro estava em um dia normal
no trabalho quando cheguei no saguão do
world trade center
eu vi um agito uma correria pra mim eu
pensei que fosse um filme porque nova
york a gente não sabe quanta gravando o
filme ou quando é uma corrida eu
continuei a minha rota quando eu tinha
que trocar o elevador
eu já vi pessoas ensanguentadas e uma
gritaria
aí eu não falei não vou continuar eu não
vou pegar o elevador e aí eu comecei
peguei as saídas de emergência comecei a
descer as escadas quando eu já cheguei
de novo no saguão eu já vi já e não era
mesmo filme o que eu tinha pensado era
uma cena bem real eu comecei correr como
todo mundo quando eu já tinha saído eu
olhei pra cima eu vi uma chuva de papéis
em um buraco temendo em uma das torres e
ninguém realmente naquele momento era
muito por muito recém a gente não sabia
o que tinha acontecido não sabe se o
avião uma bomba não sabia superman
ninguém sabia nada e aí a gente
é é a gente fiquei lá conversei com a
minha família vai acontecer alguma coisa
no f60
só que eu estou bem mas estava bem
embaixo das torres
porque todo mundo aqui embaixo
fotografando tudo mais até então o que
eu vi um outro avião entrando nas torres
neste momento foi um estrondo tremendo
foi um estrondo que chacoalhou
totalmente na minha vida e aí foi que a
gente tinha certeza que outros 800
travar o estado estava em um ataque não
sabe o que aconteceu nunca tinha vivido
isso na minha vida e as pessoas como eu
começava o perceber as pessoas
conversando com outras pessoas lá em
cima que estavam se que quando é eu
presenciei as pessoas se jogando tão foi
algo muito forte pra mim pra minha vida
e no dia seguinte é eu ainda bom ai
caíram as torres eu corri pra mim é
salvar contra aquela fumaça toda
no dia seguinte eu estava no trem em do
the daily em post lá eu reconheci um
aluno que conheci dente mente foi um
aluno que eu tinha dado algum tempo que
foi um ex aluno que quase tirou a minha
vida no world trade center bom naquele
momento da minha carreira eu já tinha eu
tinha conseguido com muito esforço
chegar no patamar legal
profissionalmente então eu tinha perdido
tudo mas eu olhei para trás e vi que
tinha muita gente aprende muito mais do
que eu tinha perdido somente o trabalho
então estava no fundo do poço porque por
tudo que aconteceu em nova york
aconteceu comigo a experiência que vivi
aqui eu falo para vocês às vezes a gente
já está no fundo do poço não tem outro
lugar pra isso já está no fundo do poço
só tem lugar que é pra sair subir já
está lá embaixo que você vai fazer
a única saída é essa sim pra cima e eu
falo para vocês às vezes acontecem essas
coisas nossas vidas tremendas
a gente pede trabalho família monte de
coisa que a gente precisa se reinventar
que vem a nossa via minha próxima
minha próxima lição a gente precisa o
famoso semáforo que eu falo pare reflita
e haja não vá no hospital e tem um tempo
off eu sempre quando acontece uma
tragédia na minha vida
alguma coisa eu vou viajar eu preciso eu
saia eu vou passear
na foto eu vou me reinventar e eu chego
cheio de energia renovada é a mesma
coisa que eu falo para vocês às vezes
com a cabeça quente a gente faz besteira
foi o que eu fiz eu sair aí eu viajei
rola com tempos as leis já tinha um
monte de idéias
só que o estado norberto não era um
lugar que as pessoas queriam estudar
naquele momento eu não ia conseguir
trazer gente precisava estados unidos
então eu comecei me infiltrar nas
comunidades nas colônias de latinos
emigrantes e começar a montar a minha
primeira escola de inglês
bom a única coisa que eu saberá dar a
aula trabalhar com escolas intercâmbio
aí eu fiz das escolas o meu verdadeiro
palco como eu tinha estudado teatro eu
acabei fazendo um verdadeiro palco dava
aula encenava mesmo tempo e aí foi um
sucesso e eu comecei como a primeira
escola segundo até tema sétima escola a
franquia e fui crescendo e aí eu vi
grava na hora eu tende ao tentar a minha
faculdade univel meu sonho americano que
assim se for mal acabei me formando a
estudei nos estados unidos e comecei a a
a desenvolver tudo isso aí é dada às
escolas
depois bom quando eu já estava superbem
que as escolas saibam agora eu vou
presentear eu vou viajar novamente
porque pra mim estudar não é só ficar
lendo o livro preciso conhecer outras
culturas
então vou procurar um bom bonito barato
eu vou agora agora vou pra tailândia dia
26 de dezembro
de 26 de dezembro eu fui pra thailand
quando cheguei na tailândia onde estava
rezando piloto falou assim você tem duas
opções você pega o próximo vôo
vocês ficam aconteceu ontem uma tragédia
tremenda aquino natural eu tinha a
mínima idéia do que 18 horas de avião
para chegar lá e voltar não é assim que
eu faço eu vou ficar eu vim pra ficar e
eu fiquei sem noção do que fosse um
tsunami eu acho que a gente ouvir essa
palavra antes da minha vida
e aí eu cheguei lá aí a cruz vermelha já
estava pedindo as pessoas serem vontade
de trabalhar e eu acabei ficando como
voluntário mas eu perguntei pra gente eu
não conheço país primeira vez eu não
falo thai é como é que eu vou ajudar as
pessoas e eu falo para vocês é a minha
próxima lição
é a prenda o idioma da caridade
às vezes você não precisa falar nenhum
idioma nossa linguagem corporal fala
tudo às vezes um abraço um carinho um
simples presente que eu devo uma criança
foi suficiente para eu ganhar minha
viagem no tempo
foi a melhor é a melhor experiência que
eu tive na minha vida de ajudar as
pessoas é muito forte pra mim e essa
experiência ela inspirou a cristo dá
mais
aí eu acabei indo saída paes landim e
acabei viajando acabei me formando em
relações internacionais pronuncia porque
eu queria me envolver com mais
organizações eu sentir que aquela
experiência que eu tive da tailândia que
eu precisava crescer pessoalmente
profissionalmente mas não só eu
precisava retribuir precisava
compartilhar tudo isso com o universo
e aí eu voltei pro estados unidos depois
de ter ficado um tempo na europa
e aí eu volto pra danar da crise
financeira de 2008 dos estados unidos
mas aí eu criei uma equação de vida ea
minha condição de vida dentro dessa
crise financeira eu queria uma equação
que era viajar que eu gostava mais
ganhar e dar quero retribuir ao universo
e aí eu falei bom sabe de uma coisa vou
criar um projeto que eu posso colocar
essas três coisas e funcionando
aí eu criei um projeto que esse projeto
vou pegar toda essa minha bagagem teatro
inglês e vão montar um projeto cria um
projeto que eu fiz em 54 países que eles
a ele acontece até hoje nas comunidades
e no rio de janeiro em vários países que
é eu treino pessoas que falam inglês
como língua nativa ou pessoas americanos
e eu dou uma certificação reconhecida
internacionalmente para eles
eles recebem certificado se torna
professor de inglês mas pra se tornar
professor de inglês receber certificado
eles têm que dar a aula uma quantidade
de inglês gratuitamente nas comunidades
necessárias que têm necessidades então
dessa forma eu viajei para todos esses
países não têm todas essas unidades
eu ganhei eu estou retribuindo estou
dando dessa forma a mesma experiência
que eu tive lá na tailândia
eu não conseguia falar então quando
estou ensinando as pessoas a se
comunicarem e retribuir o universo essa
foi a estratégia e projeto que acontece
até hoje
bom aí
em 2012 o brasil decolou e eu queria
decolagem do brasil
aí eu senti falta do brasil sim saudade
eu voltei para o brasil e depois que eu
voltei brasil muita gente fala se tá se
você não mudou nada você enquanto você a
lei você continua com os mesmos covis
ela é realmente mais uma coisa mais
importante
você ainda continua com a sua essência
escutei isso hoje mas ainda continua com
sua essência é que eu falo pra vocês
faça seja acontece mas manter sua
essência que isso que importa no final
do dia e uma uma dica que eu falo para
vocês que eu coloquei pra minha vida é
que eu imaginei todos os condicionais
eu queria eu podia se eu tivesse tido eu
não falo isso coloca o dérbi de ação eu
posso eu faço e aconteço eu faço
realizar
eu tirei os profissionais esse tempo da
minha vida e que a minha última lição
quero falar pra vocês é nunca perdi a
criança que mora dentro de vocês e o que
eu fazia todos os dias por um bom tempo
de dormir me olhava no espelho e às
vezes a gente não consegue encarar um
pouco espero que ele está tendo um
problema
consigo mesmo então eu antes de dormir
todos os dias eu me olhava no espelho e
eu colocava a língua pra fora
por que por que eu estava não estava
feliz com alguma coisa então aquela
linha me dizia que eu tentava me dando a
língua para fora porque eu tinha que
mudar alguma coisa tinha que fazer
alguma coisa para mudar faz desse
exercício olha o espelho vejo se tem
alguma coisa inútil
o importante é você ser feliz mas tem
que fazer alguma coisa que te faça feliz
você não tem que fazer algo para fazer
os outros felizes pra você fazer feliz
se você está feliz como você é do jeito
que você é o que você faz é ótimo
então eu não gostava de algo que queria
mudar não estava feliz em eu sabia que a
partir daquele momento que eu colocava
língua pra fora eu tinha o tempo todo o
tempo a partir daquele momento a minha
vida inteira para poder mudar que eu não
ficava que venha a próxima de que não
fique contemplando os dias vividos
penso que a partir daquele momento
atende você pode mudar tudo é você que
domina que você crie o seu futuro e pra
concluir a minha última dica é que a
alegria é um está não é um estado de
espírito é uma opção de vida
muito obrigado